[Music]
hello there welcome to playstation
grenade
i found another free game to grab right
now on ps4
and ps5 this is we were here
you'll need to act quickly though
because we were here we'll be going back
to full price on february 22nd
while you add it to your library i'll
tell you about it we were here is a
cooperative escape room type adventure
in which two
real-life players team up to solve
puzzles in a freezing castle
the thing is the players are separated
and can only use a walkie-talkie to
communicate
so right away you should know to get the
best out of this you will need a friend
to play with
or risk playing with a randomer
somewhere else in the world the first
player is confined to a small secluded
part of the castle while player 2
wanders around the halls of castle rock
each room discovered is yet another
puzzle which both players must solve
sometimes working separately but always
together to find a solution
talking is imperative in this game so if
you don't want to use a mic
maybe don't pick this one up in addition
to trying to escape
there's a hidden plot to uncover as to
why the once magnificent castle is now a
grim
location and there may be the original
inhabitants on your trail
who aren't too happy that you're in
their house to grab this simply search
we were here in the psn store on ps4 or
if you're on ps5 use the search function
on the home screen
there is a warning about the game being
made for ps4 so some features may not
marry over to ps5
perfectly oh and if you're wondering why
i'm classing this as ps plus
it's simple to play this game you need
ps plus to play online
it's sad but it's true wewer here is
also available for free
on pc via steam and it's on xbox 2 but
you'll have to pay for it there
best thing in my humble opinion is to
add this to your library for when the ps
plus games aren't your taste
or whenever we're in another lockdown
like now i'm adam from playstation
grenade was this useful i hope so
see you soon bye